comment un bon soir bonsoir quel plaisir
de vous recevoir tous les deux les nains
et straumann êtes actuellement ce que la
belgique fait de mieux avec stéphane de
groot et le taux d'imposition
alors on vous a connu avec ça
alors on danse
[Musique]
excuse moi tu es danger mais tu serais
pas en train de faire de la merde c'est
ça
quand tu es quand king kong
[Musique]
tu vois un peu dépressive du
salon mais chaque chose en son buzz de
bignon biniou mail ou sur le cas la
maladie
j'ai envie de faire un truc du genre
alors on alors on s'amuse alors eu un
bon ça met alors au s'amuse rosa alors
au cinq
[Musique]
alors on s'extasie alors on s'extasie
alors
[Musique]
alors on danse numéro un en dix-sept
pays 3 millions de disques vendus
alors il ya un mois est sorti votre
deuxième album qui est déjà numéro un
des ventes
elles sont là les deux ont dit que si la
belgique a les moyens de rester dans la
zone euro c'est grâce aux ventes de vo
figurez vous que c'est tout à fait vrai
alors cet album racine carrée inclut le
morceau formidable et papa où tu es dans
papa ou t on retrouve cette histoire de
parole un peu déchirante sur une musique
afro dance
oui c'est ça ou la fraude est c'est cool
on n'avait jamais donné c'était l'appel
national pourquoi pas c'est vrai donc
j'avoue que oui on peut le voir une fois
de plus oui noir ou quoi ou sombre
maintenant cesser la violence
c'est pas sombre surtout c'est une
question en fait c'est vraiment pas pas
où tu es en fait c'est un peu le rôle du
père quoi alors quand on est adolescent
lui en veut et nantes sont à jamais été
là pour moi mais bon c'est un peu la
phrase bateau et puis quand on grandit
aussi simplement bas il a fait son mur
veulent points et essayer de grandir et
essayer de faire toi de ton mieux quoi
c'est ça la question vraiment de la
chance on sait pas inquisiteur vis-à-vis
de qui que ce soit c'est plus de 3kw à
grand père papa fils
le plus en vue c'est juste super jeu je
passerai le message parce qu'on était à
beaucoup y en a beaucoup sué donc je
pense vraiment c'est exceptionnel aussi
bien la musique vous que clint
franchement c'est le très grande qualité
alors papa août et vous dit papa était
invisible
je ne n'ai pratiquement pas connu j'ai
vu trois quatre fois surtout que il est
parti à 9 ans donc c'est un peu
difficile de rattraper le temps perdu
votre mère est flamande de votre vrai
nom c'est paul vam aveux et que ça fait
un peu coureur cycliste non avec
l'accentuer
je suis très bien les insultes et elena
alors notre père était un architecte
rwandais c'est un fake coureurs et
dragueur ou c'est dur ça ouais c'est un
peu dur pas plus que pas plus que
n'importe quel homme en fait ouais c'est
un peu notre métier
mais sera en fait qu'elle a connue il
est mort assassiné au rwanda quand vous
aviez à 12 ans et vous dites j'étais
plus triste de voir ma tante souffrir
d'avoir perdu un frère que moi d'avoir
perdu un père dire que c'était pas dur
pour moi ça c'est ce ne serait que du
mensonge
mais c'est sûr que ça a été plus dur
pour ma tante elle l'a vraiment connu
c'est un frère qui est parti et moi
c'est vrai qu'on s'est vus évidemment et
j'ai pu mettre un visage sur sur mon
père mais mais au final la plus grosse
douleur c'est de se dire que je pourrai
jamais savoir qu'il était vraiment à
part vis à vis a alors c'est votre mère
qui vous a élevé vous vos trois frères
et votre soeur et votre mère vous
pousser à faire de la musique à chanter
et du temps bruxelles bruxelles et j'ai
failli faire de la danse classique
figurez vous vous êtes mes frères me
l'ont interdite vous avez loupé
et votre mère à nous amener en voyage en
bolivie dans des autocars avec des
vitres cassées c'est ça un petit peu
raide barreau deux mamans mais
finalement ça fait du bien ça exactement
au cerveau ça ouvre le cerveau ça bien
sûr ça nous permet de voir la vraie
dignité ailleurs en fait c'est mieux que
le all inclusive finalement à wiesen ne
sait plus nourrissants
alors à 17 ans vous lancer dans le rap
sous le nom de au ps maestro qui
deviendra évidemment stromae en rend
vers laon il le succès arrivera en 2005
quand vous vous tournerez vers la
musique électronique en fait j'avais un
petit peu économiser en travaillant dans
un fast food de connu donc j'ai pu
sortir mon premier maxi pays mais une
partie de mes études aussi et puis
finalement c'est un peu plus tard que à
la fin de mes études de cinématographie
en option sont que je fais un stage dans
une radio et qui décide de jouer le
morceau alors on danse
la suite on la connaît ça marche
tellement que vous avez vous installé en
france pour payer plus d'impôts
et ben exactement justement
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu